i wanted to mention this too so daley
wire
says gibson's bakery a family-owned
bakery that has operated overland ohio
since 1885
received a major win in its ongoing feud
with oberlin college
which encouraged and supported students
and faculty falsely accusing the bakery
of racism in 2016.
it says the jury awarded the bakery 36
million dollars in damages after
oberlin's sustained campaign against the
shop and the college fought the verdict
with every tool at its disposal the
state supreme court on tuesday declined
to hear oberlin's appeal meaning the
school will finally have to pay the
bakery that it has nearly put out of
business
gibson's family attorney told the daily
wireless statement truth still matters
david can still overcome goliath we and
the gibson family are gratified that all
judges on the court of appeals the
majority of the ohio supreme court
recognized the rights of individuals
rather than the bullying tactics of the
big institutions
in april an appeals court upheld the
multi-million dollar verdict the daily
wire reported but the college appealed
to the
ohio supreme court and they lost there
as well so they're gonna have to pay out
36 million dollars in damages
for having
almost put this business out of business
now
what happened here that's that's the end
of the story that's the happy ending and
we don't get a lot of those so we should
celebrate them when they happen
but what led to this if you don't
remember this story because there are so
many fake racism stories it's hard to
keep them all straight
why was this bakery being accused of
racism
well it's very simple actually you can
tell the story in like two sentences um
some non-white oberlin students
went to the business few years ago
tried to steal alcohol from the business
they were stealing
someone at the bakery in the gibson
family
stopped them from stealing
and that's it
that's where else that's why they're
racist
because a white person at a business
tried to stop some non-white people from
stealing from them and
therefore they're racist
um next you know there are protests
there's everything else and oberlin
college itself as an institution
is putting all of its weight behind
destroying this business and these
people
simply because they wouldn't allow black
students to steal from them
why else would you stop someone from
stealing from you except racism
right because because the the gibson
family
they invite white people to steal from
them they have a sign on the door saying
uh white people are allowed to steal
if they saw a white person walking out
the door with something they'd say oh
hey stop sir oh wait you're white never
mind go ahead go ahead do you want more
you want to grab this over here you can
have that as well you want some money
from the cash register i mean if you're
white you can have it
that's basically the the situation that
the that's the picture that oberlin
college as an institution wanted to
paint and now they've got to pay out
which is
great but it's also um
discouraging on a in another way if you
want to look at the
if you want to look at the black cloud
within the silver lining as i often tend
to do um
it's also kind of discouraging because
of what
they were so clearly defamed and
victimized here they're so clearly the
in the right so clearly the victims and
yet it took them years and i don't know
how much money to be vindicated and most
people who are
put in this situation don't have the
resources to fight like that
and so they're defamed and their lives
are destroyed and then the mob just
moves on to the next person
if you want to join my exclusive fan
base or a cult as really that's what it
is we're joy we're forming a cult then
all you gotta do is click the subscribe
button and ring the bell below uh this
video to stay up to date with all my
content and if you want even more you
can watch or listen to my show at
thedailywire.com spotify or apple
podcast
looking forward to welcoming you to the
sweet baby gang